Narrator: This is a scene
from the silent Western "Pinto Ben."
And here's what it looks like
after it's been restored.
All that gunk in the before
is chemical decomposition,
which has destroyed an estimated 75%
of American silent films.
But here is where they get saved:
the George Eastman Museum,
where archivists have rescued lost works
of filmmakers like Stanley
Kubrick and Orson Welles.
One of its current projects is this:
a Western over a century old
starring and directed by William S. Hart,
one of the biggest
movie stars of the time.
And it's particularly tricky
because it's made of nitrate.
The material is notorious
for being highly flammable
and chemically unstable,
which makes it prone to decomposition.
I'm sure you can start to smell this.
It smells like nitrate
that's starting to decompose.
My colleagues feel it
smells like a wet dog.
When it gets very bad, it's more like
if you took a dirty gym sock
and put it in a glass of sour milk.
Narrator: While "Pinto Ben" hasn't gotten
to the point of sour milk,
the clear film base has
started to discolor.
That's stage one.
Anthony: As you wind
through it, you could see
how it's becoming more
and more brownish-yellow.
This was stage two, where the
image has started to melt.
Narrator: This is where the emulsion
in the film has broken down.
Anthony: The third stage,
the film starts to ooze
and bubble like a honey-like substance.
Up to that point, parts of
it can still be salvaged.
And then stage four, it
crystallizes into a hockey puck.
After that, it becomes a
very fine brown powder.
Narrator: That process is irreversible,
and it can happen surprisingly fast,
so archivists like Anthony
have to identify decomposing films
and restore them to new film
stock before it's too late.
In silent films like this,
they may start looking
around the title cards.
Titles usually were photographed
and processed more poorly than the images.
A lot of the decomp can
start from the titles
and then work its way
through the rest of the film.
Narrator: Then they'll
start on physical repairs.
Each of these splices
marks a tear in the film
that an archivist fused back
together with liquid cement
or damaged frames that had to
be replaced with blank film.
Some of these repairs were done
before the reel came into
Eastman's possession.
Another area that needs
mending: these perforated edges.
If those perforations get ripped off,
the tear can spread inwards
and begin to affect the image.
Also, those perforations, when intact,
allow the film to move
safely through the cleaner
and scanner in the next steps.
So in areas with extensive damage ...
Anthony: The edge and the
perfs are missing completely.
Narrator: Anthony will
use this special tape
to replace the missing perforations.
By the end of this process,
the film will look something like this,
with all those white stripes
marking perforation repairs.
Once all those weakened
areas have been reinforced,
the film goes through
this ultrasonic cleaner
to remove any dust or dirt on the surface.
Then the film is finally digitized.
It goes through the scanner,
which captures each frame and
turns it into a digital file.
This process can take up to
48 hours for a two-hour film,
and the team has to do this
for every version of the film
they're going to use
for the reconstruction.
Eastman is reconstructing
"Pinto Ben" from six sources,
with each providing different
puzzle pieces of the film.
Two of the sources come from
the 1917 reissue of the film
under the title "Horns and Hoofs."
The Library of Congress
preserved the nitrate
for reel one, the first half of the film,
and the negative for reel two,
the second half of the film.
These sources have the
best image quality --
the shots look sharp and
have good contrast --
but the Library of Congress nitrate
is the least complete element.
These frames have some
yellow ooze on the side,
which marks the beginning
of the decomposition,
while these frames show
it in its later stages.
Graham: We cannot digitally restore this
because there is very
little image information
for our software to look at,
so we're going to want to use that
for as many scenes as we can,
but if frames are missing or if the decomp
and the damage is so
distracting and irreconcilable,
we'll switch to the other
nitrate print that we have.
Narrator: This nitrate
was sent over from France,
where "Pinto Ben" was released
as "Le Poney de Rio Jim."
Bryan: Some pieces were actually excised
throughout the years,
maybe because of decomp
or damage, we don't know.
Narrator: To fill in chunks
that are still missing,
the team will defer to one of three
lower-res prints of the
film from a 1924 re-release.
Altogether, these prints
contain the most information,
since they have the highest
number of frames intact.
But the image quality here
is probably the roughest.
Graham: You can see the focus
is a little bit fuzzier,
it's a little bit flatter,
the contrast isn't as good.
Narrator: They can play with
the contrast to help correct
for any obvious quality
jumps between frames,
and color grading will help
tie everything together.
Graham: And then from all
those different elements
and all those different frames,
we assemble as complete
a version as possible.
Narrator: Once a timeline
of all the best shots
has been created, digital
restoration begins.
The first thing to correct
is this shaky movement
you see between frames.
Often it's the result of
film shrinking over time.
Shrunken film doesn't go
through the scanner as well,
so you can end up with an unstable image.
Chris: We know in analog
film, there's a little bit
of a slight vibration in the film image,
but if it were to regularly
distractingly move up and down,
we would try and eliminate
that to a degree.
The thing that this element suffers from
is mostly scratching.
Narrator: Software helps detect these,
but it's not a perfect solution.
Chris: In this film,
there's a lot of wallpaper
and a lot of vertical lines
that resemble these types of scratches,
so I put in a scratch that's very thick,
it's going to say,
hey, I'm this line on
the wallpaper, right?
I should be removing that.
Narrator: He can use the same
kind of programmed filters
to help detect dark dirt, light dust,
or other errant artifacts,
like the stray eyelash
or hair that may have become
embedded into the print.
Chris: So that's just
a piece of errant dirt
that fell onto the film at some point.
Narrator: Other artifacts
might be captured
in the image itself,
for example, if there was dirt
on the printer or a camera negative
when the film was printed
however many years ago.
You tend to find the most dirt
and dust at the ends of the film.
Bryan: Those would be
exposed to the elements more.
Just sitting in a can,
it would be either heads out or tails out,
so that would accumulate dust
when you're putting it in
the can, taking it out.
Narrator: In general, the
more popular a film was
and the more times it
was shown in theaters,
the more likely it is to have suffered
extensive wear and tear, from
scratches and thumbprints
to spots like this, where
the emulsion's rubbed off,
a common effect of repeated projection.
The last step in the
process: color grading.
Here, the team has the scanned frames
of "Pinto Ben" up on the screen
and the nitrate film out
on the inspection table.
The goal is to make the
colors on that screen
match those in the physical reference
as closely as possible.
This takes a lot of
precision and teamwork.
Bryan: Warmer, colder?
Graham: I would say warmer,
but I feel like we've lost
some of the saturation.
It's a very deep, vivid,
almost radioactive yellow.
Narrator: They have to be very gentle
with a print like this
as they go through and inspect
the color in each scene.
Graham: As you can see,
the film is bending
in one direction, as
well as these edges here
are buckling out a little bit.
Those are all signs of warpage
and physical deterioration
of the film stock.
If that gets any worse,
this element might not be able
to be scanned in the future.
And so when we inspect it, we
move through it very slowly,
because the last thing we want to do
is to introduce more
damage to the film print.
Narrator: At the end of the process,
the film looks like this --
pretty close to how it was originally seen
by audiences back in 1915.
And that's the goal.
We're trying to present
the film as an artifact
and an art form the way it
was originally presented.
Narrator: This whole process
can take up to two years,
which means many movies
are deteriorating faster
than archives can preserve them.
If we have a unique print where we know
that this is the last
surviving element of a film
and we notice that it's
starting to decompose,
that will go to the top of our
preservation priority list.
Narrator: "Pinto Ben" is one
of nine William S. Hart films
Eastman is restoring, and
one of thousands of movies
the museum's helped rescue
from being lost forever.